so the interesting part of this movie is
that the people who were you know having
to in their view give up their way of
life all right when the 1964 Civil
Rights Act was passed felt that they
were being discriminated against that
they were the ones who were being made
to suffer and it reminded me so much of
the gay marriage argument so many I
think people in this country who were
against that the Kim Davis's of the
world
we're like what about our rights what
about our right to take away your rights
and yeah and you see the deep that these
these things aren't new the biggest the
biggest argument that the South had the
Dixiecrats were take time we don't need
to change things quickly it's all even I
know it's a hundred years yeah you know
and and that's a it was something that
LBJ needed to risk he knew he had to
risk that and he did he risked it he
lost the support of all the Dixiecrats
come 1964 right well um what do you
think about the fact that if bathrooms
because we were talking about the
bathroom thing is is again an issue in
this country that transgender people
somehow have not risen to the top of the
political charts about where they can go
to the bathroom argot because their
groups are running at the American
Family Association has said it's
collected over a million signatures
online to you know get back at Target
for saying you can where you want
and it's which is they just think really
a comma GOG they couldn't demagogue
anymore about gays and lesbians because
too many of us are out too many people
know us so they took the same old script
other recruiting children preying on
children threatening children creeping
and banners that was the script that was
what they said about gay men forty years
ago and they're just taking that and
applying it now to trans women and it's
and trans women and men use
bathrooms all over the country and have
forever and they have actually no cases
to point to where a trans person has
exploited a civil rights protection to
prey on a child there are lots of cases
where
argument wait is it about Mexicans it
isn't I did I will check building a wall
we need to build a stall that's
beautiful
tremendous
stalls all along
and I'll make caitlyn jenner pay for it
no Trump said Caitlyn could use the
bathroom he's good on this exactly easy
doesn't care about drags right I think
we're growing up as a society and you
know there's even a nation providing a
temporary respite I think that people
hate Mexicans of the Republican base
hated Mex is more racist than they are
trans phobic and their Tony Rupp won
that but we'll be back
but relit ago no I just can't wait wait
I can't make the alternative argument
yes we go yes first of all I completely
reject the comparison of either Mexicans
since you brought them up illegal aliens
or gays to the black experience in
America and I think that's an important
point that always needs me and I agree
your vodka angry waves and right against
your experience and I hate that
comparison all the time and I would say
that the argument on the bathrooms it's
not that transgendered people are gonna
go and molest children it's that once
you say men can go into women's
bathrooms then you were out shopping
with their little daughters and don't
have mommy to bring her in there it's
not that the trans are gonna molest them
it's that a child molester now has the
right to go into that bathroom oh that's
a child molester doesn't need
to put on a dress to enter bathroom you
can google sexually assaulted in a
restroom and you get thousands of
examples of cisgender straight men you
know who the child molester is it's
Dennis Hastert yes who is
sitting watching boys shower year after
year in a lazy boy chair because he
wanted to make sure nothing weird was
going on and so he watched the boys
shower I saw in the paper today Joe
Paterno was aware of Jerry Sandusky in
1976 this is the child molesting that
bill it's not about that makes your
argument against Republicans and doesn't
make your argument for him that okay men
will not become there's a rescue dog it
should be bigger more important point
which is it's good I think the
Republican Party has gotten over their
obsession with these web issues I don't
think wedge issues I'm sorry because
Donald Trump they had their choice to
pick Rick Santorum Mike Huckabee Ted
Cruz all these people who trade their
way across the country and they opted
for The New Yorker with three wives who
doesn't give a about any of this he
doesn't care about gay marriage he
doesn't care about where people go to
the bathroom I mean he says nobody reads
the Bible more than me no one actually
numbered hey no and then number two
number two is yo and number 2
Corinthians at the time
good news I don't think it's I don't
think attach that to it yeah let's wait
three more election cycles and say yes
because we're all litigating access to
birth control we thought that was a
settled issue that even people opposed
abortion we're in birth control but
suddenly Bobby Jindal made plan B or he
wants to make contraception he's a
religious Catholic or was a governor of
Louisiana he wanted to make it over the
counter
I actually I mean I I worry about some
of the same issues I don't think this is
temporary only 26 percent of the
population we had of places I was going
to say maybe it's time for a viable
third party that is socially conscious
but yet fiscally responsible right into
those keys those are called those are
House Democrats